[Música]
el ejército ruso bombardeo los
alrededores de kiev y ser michi en el
norte ucraniano estos ataques llegan tan
solo un día después de que rusia
anunciara una supuesta reducción de las
operaciones militares en ambas ciudades
para generar confianza mutua de cara a
las negociaciones tenemos reportes de
nuestros enviados especiales
y otro día de guerra es otro día de
movimientos diplomáticos en el intento
de fortalecer las alianzas geopolíticas
un presidente joe biden le prometió 500
millones de dólares más en ayudas a su
homólogo ucraniano volodymyr selenski y
el ministro de exteriores ruso serguéi
lávrov se encuentra de visita en china
el próximo 10 de abril francia vota en
primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales las encuestas siguen
dando favorito a emanuel macrón seguido
de la candidata de extrema derecha
marine lepén este miércoles la campaña
se centró en la agricultura
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo serán hoy y es un
gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos este noticiero
actualizando la información sobre la
guerra en ucrania allí el ejército ruso
bombardeo los alrededores de kiev y
chernin hits en el norte ucraniano según
autoridades ucranianas
estos ataques llegan tan solo un día
después de que rusia afirmara que
reduciría las operaciones militares en
ambas ciudades para generar confianza
mutua de cara a las negociaciones el
pentágono de eeuu afirmó también que los
rusos comienzan a retirarse de la
central nuclear de chernóbil
y al menos 300 personas han muerto en
heart kit la segunda ciudad más grande
de ucrania las autoridades locales
también reportan que los bombardeos
constantes por parte de rusia han
destruido más de 1.500 edificios nuestro
enviado especial romeo la angula viajó
hasta este punto ucraniano y desde allí
nos relataba previamente como está
jarquín después de más de un mes de
guerra
cuando después de tres días de camino
llegamos por fin a jarquín la segunda
ciudad de ucrania situada al noreste del
país a 40 kilómetros de la frontera con
belarús jarquín es una ciudad mártir
constantemente bombardeada después de
cinco semanas por las tropas de vladimir
putin
los bombardeos golpean prácticamente
toda la ciudad
según el alcalde jarquín hay más de 1500
edificios destruidos y afectados por la
artillería rusa y un centenar de
guarderías y escuelas
hay al menos 300 muertos civiles por el
momento probablemente son más porque una
gran parte se encuentra todavía entre
los escombros
estamos delante de un edificio simbólico
detrás de mí la sede del consejo
regional de jarquín al principio de la
invasión rusa un tiro de misil balístico
impactó este monumento
este golpe fue visto en el mundo entero
porque fue filmado por una cámara de
seguridad y fue masivamente compartido
en las redes para mostrar la fuerza
desplegada por vladimir putin con el fin
de someter a ucrania a
los rusos han fracasado en conquistar la
ciudad todo lo que pueden hacer es
realizar ataques aéreos y fuego de
artillería
para quiénes
juntar
y archiv contaba con alrededor de millón
y medio de ciudadanos hoy más del 30 por
ciento de los habitantes se han marchado
de la ciudad el metro se ha convertido
en un inmenso dormitorio donde todas las
tardes son miles los que llegan a
refugiarse cuando comienza el toque de
queda
mientras el presidente de estados unidos
joe biden prometió a su homólogo
ucraniano volodymyr selenski 500
millones de dólares más en ayudas
directas su secretario de estado antonio
link quien está de gira por israel y el
magreb por el frente ruso el canciller
sérguei lávrov está en china alimentando
su alianza geopolítica más en el
siguiente informe
volvieron a reafirmar su amistad sin
límites más de un mes después del inicio
de la invasión rusa en ucrania en una
visita oficial a beijing serguéi lávrov
anunció la llegada de un nuevo orden
mundial en estrecha colaboración con su
aliado chino
estamos viviendo una etapa importante en
la historia de las relaciones
internacionales
nosotros junto a ustedes y con nuestros
partidarios avanzaremos hacia un orden
mundial multipolar justo y democrático
no lo he visto
desde el 24 de febrero beijing se niega
a condenar la ofensiva rusa en ucrania y
denunció las sanciones occidentales
contra moscú además de esta reunión
bilateral también afganistán y su
estabilidad han estado en la agenda de
rusia y china- con motivo de una reunión
de sus siete países vecinos con pakistán
e irán entre otros por parte de eeuu las
visitas oficiales no han dejado de
sucederse el secretario de estado
estadounidense continúa su gira regional
por el magreb tras haber estado el
martes en marruecos anthony blinken
viajó el miércoles a argelia para
reunirse con su homólogo washington
quiere repensar la naturaleza de las
relaciones entre los dos países con esta
situación y brain hablamos de la
situación en ucrania por supuesto y
también hablamos de la amplitud y
profundidad de nuestra relación
incluidos los aspectos bilaterales de la
misma también estábamos deseosos de
discutir los aspectos económicos de
nuestra relación para promover mejor los
lazos comerciales y de inversión
argelia es un aliado de rusia y un
importante productor de gas washington
le pide que aumente sus exportaciones
para mitigar el impacto de la guerra en
ucrania entretanto la agencia de las
naciones unidas para los refugiados
informó que ellas más de 4 millones los
ucranianos que han salido del país de
entre ellos la onu cifra en 2,3 millones
las personas que han huido hacia la
vecina polonia de largo el país que más
refugiados ha recibido otros 6,5
millones de personas se habrían
desplazado dentro de ucrania en busca de
resguardo frente a las hostilidades
en francia en donde el próximo domingo
10 de abril se celebrará la primera
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
hoy una encuesta realizada por ifop
fiducia le otorgó la cabecera en
intención de voto al actual presidente
emmanuel macrón con un 28% de votos a su
favor la segunda vuelta pasaría junto a
él la candidata de extrema derecha
marine lepén que sumaría un 21 5 por
ciento de los sufragios casi un 32% para
la ultraderecha sumando los votos para
el ix el tercero es el candidato de
izquierda jean luc mélenchon con un 15%
lejos de poder alcanzar la segunda
vuelta la candidata de los republicanos
valérie pécresse y el controvertido
candidato de extrema derecha eric se
mousse obtendrían un 10% un 10,5 por
ciento cada uno este miércoles los
candidatos cortejaron a los agricultores
presentando planes para darles más
sustento y hacer que francia sea
autosuficiente veamos en el siguiente
informe
una campaña presidencial cada día viene
con su cuota de promesas este miércoles
fue sobre la agricultura la francia
actual que anteriormente fue una nación
líder en el sector ya no es un lugar en
el que prosperen los agricultores fabián
guste él quiere cambiar todo eso y
asegurarse de que el país tenga al menos
a medio millón de agricultores
solange y post creo que es lo mínimo que
podemos hacer para responder al desafío
alimentario y al desafío agroecológico
esto implica incluir entre 20.000 y
25.000 agricultores al año lo que supone
un esfuerzo gigantesco cuando eso lo
estamos incluyendo la mitad
los candidatos de la derecha extrema
prometieron luchar por la seguridad de
los agricultores cueste lo que cueste
la mayoría del campo es soy víctima de
una delincuencia inaceptable que es la
delincuencia itinerante a menudo de
origen extranjero itiner oms
tenemos que dejar de firmar acuerdos de
libre comercio con todo el mundo es una
competencia desleal con la que es
imposible convivir la diva
el ex pastor ya en la sal se vinculó una
vez más con el público y sus luchas
los agricultores no son el enemigo y no
son los que contaminan no son los que
están calentando el planeta y al menos
no mienten como nosotros los polis nos
mande para comer noble política
los mismos candidatos ya habían expuesto
su caso ante el lobby de cazadores el
presidente marrón estaba demasiado
ocupado pero al final consiguió su apoyo
los candidatos que critican a los
lobbies criticaron el movimiento
el señor strain tiene derecho a opinar
ha sido un invitado constante en el
palacio presidencial durante años el
chocante ver como los lobbies se vuelven
tan influyentes bajo el mandato de
manuel marco y vamos a dar un breve
repaso por las noticias de américa
latina' crisis política en ecuador la
ministra de gobierno alexandra vela
renunció por un desacuerdo con el
mandatario guillermo lasso por la pugna
de poderes que el mandatario pide con el
legislativo con ella son dos los
ministros que han dimitido
laso planteó disolver la asamblea de
mayoría opositora o no apoyar sus planes
de gobierno la constitución le permite
hacerlo en los primeros tres años de
mandato si lo hace se convocaría a
nuevas elecciones
y la corte interamericana de derechos
humanos ordenó a perú frenar
temporalmente la decisión del tribunal
constitucional del país de liberar al ex
presidente alberto fujimori la corte y
de h ya mostró su desacuerdo ante la
medida por entender que vulnera el
derecho de acceso a la justicia para las
víctimas de los crímenes imputados a
fujimori
en el salvador se podría endurecer el
régimen de excepción que comenzó el
domingo a petición del presidente bukele
el mandatario le pidió a la asamblea
reunirse de manera extraordinaria para
aprobar nuevas medidas contra las
pandillas aunque no especificó en qué
consistirían el gobierno afirma que las
medidas sirve para enfrentar el repunte
de los homicidios
y en la frontera entre bolivia y chile
cientos de migrantes venezolanos
intentan cruzar ilegalmente a través de
una peligrosa franja que divide ambas
naciones al menos cinco personas han
muerto en 2022 en el paso fronterizo
donde chile tiene desplegados a decenas
de militares ante una de las peores
crisis migratorias de la región marina
sardiña tiene más detalles
sobre mí ha recorrido más de 5000
kilómetros desde venezuela lo hace
acompañada de sus dos hijas y dos
sobrinos desde las gélidas temperaturas
y el miedo espera ahora que un
traficante le ayuda a cruzar la zanja el
último paso para llegar a chile es muy
río es
demasiado
te falta mucho la respiración
la gripe las niñas o sea es muy feo cada
día cientos de personas intentan pasar
la frontera pisiga gol sane que se para
bolivia y chile y que está cerrada desde
hace dos años por el cob y 19 un
complicado periplo que en lo que va de
año ha acabado con la vida de al menos
cinco migrantes entre ellos un niño que
huyen de las múltiples crisis que
atraviesa su país más de seis millones
de personas han salido de venezuela
desde 2015 según acnur medio millón
residen en chile
vamos a hacer seguir porque
muchos familiares de nosotros y bueno
una mejor oportunidad que la parte de la
fosa que separa ambas naciones está
custodiada por los militares chilenos
desplegados desde hace meses luego de
que el ex presidente sebastián piñera
impusiera el estado de excepción por la
crisis migratoria para evadirlos los
migrantes pasan por cruces ilegales con
ayuda de traficantes que les cobran
hasta 100 dólares por persona es decir
pudimos pasar colombia-ecuador y pasamos
perú a pie porque no pasaba y estamos
pasando bolivia porque no vas a chile
porque no llega a chile el pasado
febrero las cancillerías de venezuela y
chile sin relaciones diplomáticas desde
1978 acordaron una mesa de trabajo para
abordar la problemática en la frontera
sin lograr una pronta solución
acabamos con un récord histórico un
nuevo hito en la historia del deporte
femenino este miércoles el camp nou de
barcelona registró una entrada de 91 mil
553 espectadores para ver el partido de
champions league femenina entre el fc
barcelona y el real madrid la cifra
superó la del mundial la de la final del
mundial femenino de
1999 entre eeuu y china nuestra
corresponsal en barcelona el issga seng
él nos reportaban más temprano los
detalles
el clásico barça madrid de fútbol
femenino logo esta noche batir el récord
de asistencia mundial en un partido de
fútbol femenino el anterior remonta a
1999 en california en un partido de
final de mundial con algo más de 90 mil
personas y esta noche pues en 91 mil
553 personas pues asistieron a este
espectáculo deportivo que se saldó con
un resultado de 5 contra 2 el barça
logra así el llegar por cuarta vez
consecutiva a semifinales de la
champions en este estadio donde pues
habitualmente juegan los chicos y esta
noche por primera vez el jugaban ellas
ante un público y de hecho el mosaico
que se desplegó varias veces durante el
partido
más que el empoderamiento de la mujer
simboliza este cambio de ega aunque
queda mucho recorrido todavía para
lograr la igualdad salarial por ejemplo
pues esta noche muchos
es que este partido logre el
reconocimiento del valor del fútbol
femenino en la sociedad
hasta aquí este repaso a la actualidad
internacional sigan con nosotros en
france 24 y les recordamos que pueden
actualizar toda la información en
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
[Música]